[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about kuipers betrayal over Cersei
I'm sure you've already heard about it
on my channel but the reason we're going
to talk about it again is because it was
heavily hinted to come true by the
season 8 premiere as a matter of fact
Qyburn might have already betrayed her
in that very same episode first we see
Qyburn in season 8 he notifies his queen
about the fall of the wall and the night
Kings march south Circe says good let
them kill each other and leaves Kai
burns face expression to death says at
all she is gone for crazy now how might
have Qyburn betrayed Cersei that episode
well I believe Kaiba remembers the
Delaine Circe almost killed him at
Harrenhal while the Starks saved it I
think I burn wants revenge against all
the Lancers and I think it might not be
searched a hoarder Clyburn to employ
Bronn to kill Tyrion and Jaime I think
it's all Khyber's doing without Cersei
knowing any of this I think it was not
services ordered to Bronn I think it was
hybrids
Cersei probably doesn't want Jamie to
die if she wanted to she would have just
given the word to the mountain to do it
then in the season 7 finale she couldn't
and she didn't she still loves him she
doesn't want him dead it makes no sense
for Cersei not to kill Jaime in the
season 7 finale but in order it in the
season 8 premiere also I firmly believe
Tyrion is working for Cersei now
especially after season 8 premiere so it
makes no sense for her to kill him it's
quite popular theory that Cersei and
Tyrion made the deal behind closed doors
in season 8 episode 1 Samson is
concerned about the lane search jobs and
talks with Tyrion she has seen if you
really think Circe is going to help them
Tyrion watches for his sister and says
they're there to help
Tyrion defend Cersei which might add
some fuel to an already popular theory
about a secret deal the two siblings
might have made during their closed-door
meeting in the season 7 finale
especially sense has replied to that I
thought you were the cleverest man I've
ever met
implying - how can Tyrion be so naive
but then again he's known for reading
people as good as books so does he
really think Circe is going to help or
is this part of his plan it's going to
be interesting how tyrion story plays
out later on in the season
Tirion might be working with sir say the
log brain gives they might also be a
hint of Tyrion's betrayal and he saw it
additional even if sir Centurion don't
have a secret deal it still what that
makes sense for her to order Tunis
homicide now when she recently had a
chance to do it but she did not want to
she stopped the mountain from doing it I
believe it sky burns doing and I believe
this is the beginning of his revenge
against the Lannisters in the end I
believe the mountain will betrayed
Cersei on KY burns orders and they'll be
the one to either kill her himself or
help someone else do it
like for an example or a stark the
mountains rolled by this theory will be
helping Aria to pass by Queen's Guard
and put an end to Cersei if this would
come true to those who confirm another
tear if mine which Qyburn has been
working for where is this whole time but
also for the good of the Starks the
mountain will be of a huge importance in
areas homicidal Cersei Lannister as the
mountain is in my opinion loyal towards
his creator
Qyburn who is not Circe's loyalist and
who brought back the mountain to life
only to act as his minion which is part
of a bigger plan of vengeance otherwise
it would not make any sense for Qyburn
to bring the mountain back to life who
back in the third season almost killed
him just like it doesn't make any sense
for Qyburn to be loyal to the Lannisters
whose prisoner he was and not to the
Starks who saved his life it's all part
of a bigger plan dimensions from the
very beginning since the very first
episode Qyburn appeared on show they
were raising more and more yet
unexplained and unanswered questions for
example why did Qyburn even decide to
save the mountains life life of the same
man that almost killed him at Harrenhal
as we all know for unknown reasons
Qyburn ended up among the Norton and
Riverlands prisoners at Harrenhal
when the mountain abandons the castle
has all captives put to the sword
Qyburn however survives the injury at
his throat and the vacants from the
castle is taken by the northern army
after he awakes he identifies himself to
Robb Stark well tell us the stark turns
to his wound Sakai burns saving the
mountains life who back in the third
season almost killed him seems highly
strange also her sky burn been able to
use spy capabilities of same old birds
diversity as used in the previous
seasons similar birds that very
Centurions concerns about their loyalty
replied with men can be fickle but birds
Elvis trusts we all know that various
cannot be fooled that easy
shanlee versus known as the man of
knowledge and whispers as a man that
knows every step of every living man in
Seven Kingdoms
it varies fully trust someone that
someone will not be trained even if that
would mean the death were that someone
in case you don't know little bird
services fun and group of spies which he
educates gives sweets and provides them
with protection in return for the
information they bring him his
sophisticated intelligence network which
is one of the largest in the world and
spans both Westeros and Essos due to his
vast web of intelligence sources first
is the spiritually known as a spider
this fact gives me even more doubt about
bears not knowing about a group of his
spies that supposedly betrayed him all
this means that Qyburn is most likely
working for Varys and is waiting for the
right time to be traced Cersei and
orchestrate her death as we all know
Qyburn insert she became extremely close
considering the fact that Cersei treated
people around her especially the just
arrived ones to paranoia and suspicious
thoughts
Qyburn however gained search his full
trust by bringing the mountain back to
life after he was seriously wounded by
spear coated in Manticore venom during
his fight against Oberyn Martell after
death Cersei named Qyburn as master
whispers as the varices replacement on
the small council following destruction
of the great Sept of Baelor Qyburn
becomes hand of the Queen - Cersei the
new queen of the Andals and the first
men
even if Qyburn managed to bribe few
versus all birds and even if those few
spice agreed to betray Varys
there's no way that various would not
find it out there is no way that none of
them would send whispered words this is
also raising a few important questions
inter probably wondering if Qyburn a
little birds are loyal to Eris quite a
little birds inform Qyburn about the
Wildfire who later informed Cersei about
it
which led to annihilation of the great
Sept of Baelor along with toasters his
enemies
well search his plane to destroy the
great Sept of Baelor along with all the
important people inside match perfectly
with vs. plan and in my opinion were
sexually ordered Qyburn in his old Birds
to find out if the world virtually is
under the great Sept of Baelor and if
actually is to inform Circe about it
immediately Maris is a smart man he was
aware that if Circe was to wipe out most
of the leadership with wildfire it would
have resulted with her losing all allies
and it would have made Danis conquest
far easier
in fact that's exactly what happened
just as very suspected Cersei wiped out
all her enemies analyzed which gave him
an opportunity to make new allies for
Dany
in this case with Olenna Tyrell but he
sacked various suit covers help manage
to provide the new ally for his queen
and made a nice takeover even easier
also the fact that highborn brought
Mountain back to life who back in third
season almost killed him is something
that I cannot get over it would only
make sense if it's a part of a bigger
plan of vengeance
it could be that Qyburn created a
monster only to get even closer to
Cersei which would allow them and the
time comes to easily kill Cersei while
she thinks that he is her most trusted
protector as the mountain was her
closest and the only guard to the past
few seasons it's safe to say that he
will continue to be in the final season
as well if this theory comes true it
would only prove once again how
brilliant is the mind of Ares which
would once again confirm where sky
intelligence and cunning skills also if
this theory comes show it would confirm
an old theory of mine in which re is
going to kill Cersei with the mountains
help let me also remind you that Qyburn
claims that mountain has vowed not to
speak until all sources enemies and all
evil are gone from the realm here the
mountain will betray Cersei and will
help Jaime to put an end to the mad
Queen as she is her own worst enemy and
then the mountain will talk again this
will represent arguably the greatest
waste in series even greater than
Bolton's and phrase betrayal over Starks
Cersei will be betrayed by her two most
trusted people would be killed by her
most trusted advisor and by her most
trusted guard as I said in one of my
previous videos if Qyburn truly works
for Varys then some of the main
characters might still be alive
in season 7 episode 3 Qyburn and the
mountain are present in the dungeons
when Cersei confronts hilarious and her
daughter today in send who had killed
her daughter Marcella Baratheon Cersei
tells tiller anything that Khyber
managed to ascertain that they had
poison her daughter with the long
farewell Cersei kisses them with the
long farewell and Qyburn gives Cersei
the antidote sir second first with
Qyburn who sure sir the poison will mean
certain death pertain but how long the
poison will take to kill depends largely
on the strength of the victims
Constitution Qyburn and others then
leave a distraught Illyria to mourn with
her dying daughter a bit later in the
same episode Jamie gives all in a poison
thinking he poisoned her did they really
die as a matter of fact were they even
poisoned no Qyburn is the one providing
the supposed poison to Cersei in the
cells the suppose poisoned Jaime give
stolen I is also most likely coming from
Qyburn since his Lannister's maester
this theory which Qyburn doesn't really
work for Cersei it wasn't a poison type
of provided to Cersei and Jaime to use
and her enemies
Elena and tyene are still alive and he
was yet another master plan of the
cunning spider Varys I believe Qyburn is
working for various and I believe he
wants vengeance on easily insert sue
almost killed him and I believe he'll
help the Sharks bring the justice upon
Cersei please let me know what do you
think in the comment section down below
do you agree that the entire Qyburn
story is quite strange from being saved
by the Starks to becoming Lee inserts
most trusted man answers his right hand
as well as him saving the mountain the
same man who almost killed him to me all
of this would only make sense if it's
all part of bigger plan of vengeance
against the Lannisters in their met
doubt the mountain in conclusion I think
if searched save one in her siblings
dead she would have just killed them at
King's Landing in the season 7 finale
and would not wait for them to leave and
then ordered their home side I believe
it sky burns orders to bran and they're
not coming from Cersei and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace